welcome to every damn day we're gonna
talk about a robot sex brothel we're
gonna talk about Pete Davidson
masturbating to his fiancee Ariana
Grande but first check out this video
this is gritty he's the new mascot of
the Flyers he's dancing and this is a
very controversial mascot some people
are afraid of them some people like
Chris you're from Philly what are you
getting great I don't know how to feel
about it at all I don't know if I like
them or love them I'm not sure which one
it is with that good old Philadelphia
education and now here is for his first
game at least you didn't shoot in the
nuts it's not aerodynamic so I feel like
he's got that mascot body where it's
like you got like a hula hoop around the
middle and the rest of you is just kind
of looks like I was a mascot myself I
was a very attractive mascot feel free
to look at the footage that he pulled
off his head it was like a smoke show
you're like no it's like Beauty and the
Beast speaking of making love I'd like
to turn to the next story
flip that headline Jillian so in Houston
a sex brothel is opening up
but not just any sex problem it's a
robot sex brothel show that video this
is from the local news station that's a
robot a robot I love that
he doesn't know it's a robot because it
looks like a baby and it's creepy
they're all robots win to to have sex
with humans so that this is very
repetitive dances I bet they put all
those fake legs from yesterday just
walks over there maybe they had sex with
humans so I was like why would we care
of robots when I have sex with you
what worldly living in that robots are
just walking around I mean we got a
gritty so unsanitary can you imagine
they say a clean nail salons to and
toenails fell off I'm telling you they
don't clean it I do hope to have you
ever looked at a hotel room you found
pants in a hotel and I there's no way
they get in there and just I do think
it's gross and weird I thought it's like
if that's what these people want to do
you haven't had sex with an object
before no here we go it is okay you're
gonna pretend they haven't had sex with
an object before I paid for it it's mine
I take an object look like an 18 year
old boy it's purple
what I keep thinking about is when this
fails and they're like what are we gonna
do liquidation sale or whatever they're
gonna do except all these sextiles are
gonna wind up in the ocean and they're
gonna be bobbing out there and the big
garbage this is bad for the environment
it's weird
now dolphins left upset by is that it's
a now there's a place you go to have sex
with these dolls as opposed to buying
your own like everyone no one has an
issue with buying a sex doll so the
issue is used right which I'm like that
feels if anything more efficient by jet
skis do you have a jet ski in the house
but you cool if you go on vacation and
great question as my I asked my
girlfriend hypothetically I would be
offended like what is wrong with me
that's so would you like hey can I go
out and have sex with the road Jordan
does your girlfriend letting you
masturbate oh yeah so would your would
your girlfriend consider it cheating if
you masturbated what if you masturbated
with the use of an aid say a lubricant
no flashlight
I bet remote control I bet she'd
probably feel funky about it but so well
I guess I like this today me and you
both are traveling a lot would deepen
your way will allow you to no I don't
think she would like it cheating I
wouldn't be oh you cheated on me I'd
like you're weird do you think it would
be worse then if your boyfriend cheated
on you with a real person it was I would
be pissed either way but I think with a
real person I could be like you can
understand that I could understand it
more then
it's like you have to go into this shop
with a used robot stick you're into a
robot that's used than a real life woman
doing the robot this is love the
old-fashioned way when before you get
engaged the person that you're gonna be
engaged to is famous and you jerk off to
them and that's how you show that you
like this headline in an interview with
Howard Stern Pete Davidson said anytime
we're intimate I'm always apologizing
and saying thank you
you're awesome for doing this thank you
so much I was jerking off to her before
I met her so classic romantic show that
image they're in love yeah he's crazy he
was at one point in that I mean he was
like yeah like you know I could have
never gotten Ariana Grande it's crazy
it's like no Howard Stern like of
course you could not happen this is like
him putting up that nerd shield where
he's like when she leaves him eventually
he'll be like I knew I was not good
enough the whole time and then we're all
like oh okay
so you don't think he actually very well
I don't know I can't speak to that but
he said it is like a self-deprecating
joke like I'm such a disgusting monster
that I can you believe I'm dating this
little sprite you guys she was like as
soon as I met him I was like I'm gonna
marry him which is the female version of
jerking off to someone jerked off to
some like the person that you're with
right now but you never did that call me
old-fashioned but I like to keep people
in a regular box I don't really add them
to a spank bank I have a there's a whole
industry for that I just use those
people I only
[Music]
good wholesome Chris he's got a
favorites bar lots of tabs open
old-fashioned I only have one whoo
granny yes yes our shadow is from
wolpertinger and he says this is a good
episode but I think it is weird that
Marvel has a movie called Captain Marvel
that's like if Comedy Central had a show
called Captain Marvel orange army is
growing come on man - Joe contacts robot
joke will be the new bad joke I have to
guess that it's not going to be okay
when we're in Los Angeles last week we
met with all the new comedy central's
stand-up talent and we interviewed some
of them they were all great we've got a
piece for you from that right now
[Music]
welcome - what do they think it's funny
today we have comedians Megan Gailey and
Langston Kerman we're gonna show them a
bunch of images and try to guess what
they think it's funny thank you guys so
much for coming great energy your
brother really amazing two teams
competing I feel like I dislike your
team more already your team I know but
I'm against Ryan cuz he said you looked
good and then just said hi to me all
right so first before we begin playing
we just want to get a taste of what you
think is funny so I'm gonna hold up an
image and you're just gonna flash up
whether you think it's funny or not
funny okay what do you think funny not
funny I do I just don't like old people
being the butt of jokes I'm gonna say
not funny because I think that they're
valuable parts of our society and we
should treat them fairly and Langston
you said funny I think it's I think they
should all die off
she's just wandering into nothingness I
love it so what's gonna happen is now
I'm gonna show - in jizan one card
you're gonna decide which is funnier the
red or the green yes system I'm gonna
try and be honorable but I cannot make a
prize which is funnier okay you got two
foxes all right discuss what do you
think Megan's gonna pick and then you
got to tell us red or green
what does Megan think it's funnier
they're both very cute but I think that
this guy on the right is he's got a
little bit more of like human quality
yeah so yeah let's go with green I'm
gonna go with green okay green Megan
what did you decide 100% red like
immediately when I saw it this reminds
me of my boyfriend and I I wouldn't
animals remind me of my boyfriend acting
is funny Cho this is all right can we do
it over for a light can we do a round of
no cheating thought you were gonna see
it and go Megan loves the red the red
looks like he somewhere and it's
yeah well it's not your turn legs all
right
actually it is Langston sir all right
here your to traffic options oh okay
what do you guys think it Langston's
gonna choose I mean I think legs is
gonna say green
he's a very neat fella I disagree though
cuz there look that's probably a funny
billboard in the background but he'll
have to deal with that we need organize
if you're wrong you're wrong go with
green you're going with green okay
Langston what did you choose I'll be
honest I think it's very funny that
someone would have to find their car
you're wandering around you got no sense
of very okay that's a wrap on Megan
right as surprise both of you get a mind
of Mencia season four uncensored DVD we
have thousands of those
why do you have them you know why thank
you guys so much for coming
make sure to check out Langston and
Meghan's special this Friday at 11 and
11:30
they look like young women like to get a
hold of one if you would break it one
old robot I want the windows 95 yeah
yeah I want to kiss her on the neck and
then here we go sorry someone's on the
phone
[Laughter]
[Music]